[Music]
stable and that was secondary propellant
alarm clock me this music this very
moment somewhere beyond our solar system
[Music]
Beethoven's 5th Symphony as recorded in
the golden record the travels inside the
Voyager probe voyagers goal is to
introduce humanity to any alien
life-form that it finds for the past few
decades we humans have dreamed of
exploring the final frontier not because
they are easy but because they are hard
traversing new planets discovering new
life-forms but space exploration has
other incentives that we don't usually
take into accounts
[Music]
of course we're talking about money our
solar system it is packed with natural
resources all those asteroids traveling
across the universe
they're full of goals they're full of
platinum they're full of all kinds of
precious or even some of Saturn's moons
are literally natural gas balls
when worried that Earth's natural
resources would disappear one day good
news
you don't have to be because there's
plenty to exploit out there in the solar
system and oh I can tell you we are
talking a hell of a fortune space mining
is the industry over tomorrow or maybe
it's the industry of today and well what
does Luxemburg have to do with all of
this pay attention because this video is
gonna blow your mind everyone wonders
about life on other planets but who
cares about little green men when you
can find natural resources can imagine
it mining for gold on Mars or
discovering uranium on some asteroid
near Venus this might be sounding rather
like science fiction do you well
commercial space exploration is already
a reality
[Music]
Hayabusa 2 Japanese spacecraft arrives
at ryugu asteroid to retrieve minerals
several space agencies have already
found the most valuable asteroid near
Earth and that's davida it has a
diameter of three football fields with a
resource value of an estimated 27
quintillion US dollars and I'm not
making that number up that's 27 with 18
zeros after it some satellites in our
own solar system like Titan orbiting
Saturn are even literally made out of
natural gas
[Music]
so imagine what could happen if one day
we could cheaply exploit these resources
it would mean pretty much free energy
for everybody but here comes the
question if you find gold in Australia
then that gold belongs to Australians it
will be extracted following Australian
law pretty simple now some countries
have strict regulations other countries
have more flexible ones that everybody
understands who regulates what but what
happens when that gold is on Mars who
regulates that exactly and can private
companies extract it and if that does
happen what happens if two private
companies fight over the mining rights
of one asteroid well so far nobody
really seems to care about these
potential issues except one country
Luxembourg
[Music]
yeah and that's Luxembourg that tiny
European country with a smaller
population than Manhattan as we told you
in this video Luxembourg is one of the
wealthiest countries on earth and when
you have so much money you invest your
money and invest it they have in 2016
the space resources initiative was
established and with it two hundred and
twenty three million dollars of its
national space budget was set aside for
companies working towards space mining
and as we said space mining it sounds
pretty amazing but I mean how can you
invest in something when you don't even
know it's gonna be legal but if there's
something Luxembourgish politicians like
it's money money and expertise in space
basically during the 1980s Luxembourg
was one of the first countries to pass
regulations on commercial satellites so
it's actually kind of sounds like the
perfect job for them
[Music]
our goal is to put into place an overall
framework for the exploration and
commercial use of resources from
celestial bodies such as asteroids or
from the moon at-tin schneider
Luxembourg's Deputy Prime Minister and
Minister of the economy deep space
industry and Planetary Resources two of
the leading companies in the field are
already working with Luxembourg's
governments in November of 2016
Planetary Resources & Luxenberg struck a
28 million dollar investment deal in
exchange for an unspecified equity stake
in the company both companies predict
that as soon as 2025 resources like
water oxygen hydrogen and precious
metals will be able to be extracted but
the question here is how can Luxembourg
become a leader in this field and we're
really serious about it and how much
money is involved well today we're gonna
answer all of those questions but before
we do let's look back at the history
[Music]
eagled and mars sending a spacecraft to
an asteroid pretty expensive so you know
if Mohammed cannot go to the mountain
the mountain must come to Muhammad
literally here we're not talking about
going to an asteroid that's way too
ambitious what we're talking about is
moving an asteroid away from its normal
path and causing her to orbit our planet
yes that really is possible that let us
start from the beginning according to a
study published in 2012 by the Keck
Institute for Space Studies a CR or
asteroid capture and return missions are
going to be feasible in the near future
this kind of mission will make hundreds
of tons of asteroid material available
within the earth-moon system and well
what does all of this mean well a visit
to a nearby captured asteroid would
allow for shorter trips for astronauts
which in turn would mean less of a
potential radiation hazard for the crew
and also more time to work on the
materials found in the asteroid
and also there's gonna be far less money
wasted on resources and fuel but I could
probably guess what you're thinking
right now
how on earth or should I say how not on
earth have the Space Agency's figured
out how to capture an asteroid and bring
it into our planet's orbit even a tiny
asteroid will weigh millions of tons so
we can't just arrive with a crane and
move it
look when an asteroid passes close to a
planet or a large moon its orbit changes
basically a smaller body gets attracted
to a bigger one if we can just push an
asteroid a little bit so that it gets
closer to the moon the asteroid can be
pulled into orbit around the Earth and
this could be done with a
remote-controlled rocket and if you
think I've lost my mind here it's far
from it in fact what I just told you is
the summary of a paper from the Keck
Institute based in California and this
paper was published in 2012 that's seven
years before we even made this video so
now you might be wondering is it
possible to take rock samples from an
asteroid right now and the answer to
that is yes the first ones to accomplish
this worth of Japanese the Japanese
Space Agency launched a robotic
spacecraft called Hayabusa this
spacecraft traveled to the asteroid to 5
143 Itokawa in 2010 they already had
samples from it and they're not the only
ones NASA launched another spaceship in
2016 the osiris-rex whose goal is to
reach an asteroid named Ben mu
spacecraft approached the asteroid in
August 2018 extended an articulated arm
and took a sample of the asteroids
surface material the spacecraft is going
to return to Earth in 2023 of course all
of these missions are not exactly space
mining but they are testing all of the
technologies that would be required for
commercial scale space mining this is
why in 2014 Planetary Resources revealed
a full-scale prototype of its new
spacecraft that will search for
promising mining sites but as I said at
the beginning this is not the end of the
story because nothing is ever that
simple especially when it comes to space
part of the main issue is that we don't
really know much about asteroids many of
them appear to be rubber piles and in
some cases these piles spin so rapidly
that they look more like flying saucers
other asteroids due to their composition
they might be exceptionally awkward to
manipulate we might however have more
options with solid bodies a spaceship
can dock on an asteroid and push against
it but there are complications due to
microgravity and asteroid rotation it is
possible that a number of cables could
be looped around the asteroid to hold it
securely in place all of this would
require a lot of fuel and a great deal
of money but anyway we're veering a
little too into the realm of Science and
Technology here so let's go back to the
political side of space mining shall we
[Music]
the lux
space empire as the developments of the
space mining industry progresses the
need for a legal framework a regulating
space resource utilization increases the
Outer Space Treaty of 1967 was the first
to attempt some sort of international
space law framework but during the time
the treaty was signed nobody really
cared about commercial space exploration
instead in the midst of the Cold War
there was a lot of concern about using
space as a battlefield this is why the
treaty focuses mostly on those matters
[Music]
anyway international treaties they're a
pretty weird animal in fact there's no
world police that's going to enforce
them
all we have are international sanctions
and I mean give the Trump and pence
administration another term and they'll
bring a space force orb so they say the
other day cuz we're doing a tremendous
amount of work in space I said maybe we
need a new force we'll call it the space
force and I was not really serious and
then I said what a great idea maybe
we'll have to do that that could happen
this is not exactly the first time u.s.
president has said something like this
in 1983 President Reagan proposed the
creation of the Strategic Defense
Initiative SDI
this is a project to build a space-based
anti-ballistic missile system of course
media immediately started calling it
Star Wars purpose of this project was to
defend the u.s. from Soviet missiles by
intercepting them during various phases
of their flight this technology proved
to be too complex and the project was
soon cancelled but the point here is
that nobody seemed to care about this
project violating the Outer Space Treaty
that said when it comes to space mining
the treaty states the following
[Music]
the activities of non-governmental
entities in outer space including the
moon and other celestial bodies shall
require authorization and continuing
supervision by the appropriate state
party to the treaty in other words the
treaty has two key points the first is
that a non-governmental entity this is a
private business must receive permission
from their country in order to operate
in outer space and the second point is
that you can do as much research as
you're once that's okay with everybody
but what about making profits I mean
this is really where nobody knows what
to do and this is where two countries
come into the picture America and
Luxembourg
[Music]
these are pioneers in creating a legal
framework to provide legal certainty for
investors and mining companies and this
is very important because both America
and Luxembourg have very special ways of
approaching mining most resource rich
countries like Saudi Arabia or Argentina
consider those resources to be strategic
this means as I've already mentioned
that if you live in Argentina and you
find oil it doesn't belong to you but
rather to the government and the
government can decide when and how to
exploit those resources in America and
in Luxembourg the private owner is the
one who decides this means that so far
companies will have a bigger role in
space mining and this also means that
many other countries and experts have
come up with criticisms a lot of that
criticism was heard during a UN
subcommittee that deals with the
peaceful use of space but more
controversial than the American law is
the Luxembourgish one one of the ways
vocal critics is gabriel zucman a
foreign left-wing economist who studied
under the French economist Thomas
Piketty in case you don't know picady is
the author of capital in the 21st
century a very notable book that's sort
of a revival of marxist theory this is
what being in offshore financial centre
means it's not diversification it's just
extending the logic of being a tax haven
to a new area gabriel zucman economist
at UC berkeley basically the Luxembourg
law differs from the American one in one
very important way the American law says
that they will only give permits to
American mining companies an American
mining company must have officers on
American soil and the owners must be
American residents but in the case of
Luxembourg you just need to create a
company with fiscal residence in
Luxembourg
in other words let's say an Australian
company wants to do mining on one
satellite well they just need to create
a branch with a legal address in
Luxembourg and there doesn't even need
to be a big facility they're simply a
mailbox is enough and then suddenly boom
you have the legal vehicle that you need
to go and find gold on Mars in other
words Americans can reap the benefits of
American companies doing space mining
while Luxembourgers will open up a brand
new industry to the rest of the world
and this is why so many investors are
choosing this country as a place to
start research projects this brand new
industry is precisely the target
audience of the Luxembourg space cluster
an organization working towards raising
the visibility of Luxembourg space
capabilities internationally through
collaborative research and innovative
projects
[Music]
Luxemburg space industry is currently
comprised of 30 companies 700 employees
and an average turnover of approximately
2 billion euros yes two billion the
industry today encompasses 25 companies
and two public research organizations
but hold on a second because not
everything is sunshine and rainbows
Luxembourg still has to go through a lot
of Hoops to completely privatize space
mining article 1 paragraph 1 of the
Outer Space Treaty is a pretty
interesting clause the states are under
the obligation to share the benefits
resulting from their exploration of
outer space
this could mean that if the
luxembourg-based company makes a profit
they couldn't take all of that profit
somehow they would have to work out a
way to share it with more than a hundred
and ninety countries that exists on
earth which makes it sound like not such
a great deal well luckily for Luxembourg
international law is very easy to
reinterpret in fact having no legal
precedents for space mining it's hard to
determine what exactly it does mean to
share the benefits with the rest of the
world perhaps you could claim that
mining in itself benefits humankind as a
whole maybe we could even sort things
out with some sort of international tax
that would be collected by but we'll
figure that out later it would be
collected by somebody so far what we can
say is there's virtually nobody
enforcing international law all we have
is two countries America and Luxembourg
with a clear business friendly legal
framework there now is your turn do you
think we're ready for space mining would
you like to see it become commonplace in
the next few years well please leave
your answers in the comment section
below if you want to know why Luxembourg
is so rich in the first place do check
out this other video we made and also
don't forget to visit our friends from
reconsider mediacom their the podcasts
that provided the vocals in this video
that we're not mine and if you like this
video remember we publish new ones
every week so hit that subscribe button
so you don't miss a post and as always
I'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
more of my lovely voice don't forget to
check out the reconsider podcast at
reconsider Mediacom reconsiders a
podcast that challenges you to
reconsider your views by providing
context but we don't do the thinking for
you